there's pornography in your child's
school library and it's not going
anywhere if the librarians get their way
board members of the american
association of school librarians stated
that removing material featuring graphic
depictions of sex acts from schools is
akin to banning books meanwhile the slow
creep of critical race theory in
america's schools continues and those
brave enough to stand up to it are
facing retaliation an indiana school
administrator was placed on leave for
whistleblowing that crt classes were
being taught at his school so how do
concerned parents fight back against
this radical curricula let's talk to
keisha king moms of moms for liberty
florida chapter co-chair patrice onwuka
director of the center for economic
opportunity at the independent women's
forum and charles love executive
director of seeking educational
excellence and host of the charles love
show all parents of school children so
let me begin with you charles it just
seems to me like we have reached a point
where our schools are being used to
manipulate and indoctrinate children to
a very radical agenda what can parents
do to push back against it
you know i think the biggest issue is
that most people don't know what's going
on we have active parents like the
ladies here and others who are trying to
sound an alarm we have some teachers in
the school willing to speak up but most
people don't know i mean they found out
some things when schools went remote but
the biggest issue is that we have to
make people aware you know the
congressman earlier was talking about
being full cherokee but appreciating
america and blm saying that you know
it's racist and
colonialist stole the land but you know
my family my father's family grew up in
oklahoma and i can tell go into why and
how they got there but most people don't
know that because we're not teaching
them anything so there's a lack of
education and this and no one's paying
attention to what's going on especially
the gender push and the pornography
uh patrice what are you seeing in terms
of the pushback that uh parents are
mounting against this type of radical
agenda
well number one parents are being
organized and i think groups like the
independent women's network uh
affiliated with iwf we're arming them
with the tools to be able to speak out
to seek information and to understand
exactly what their children are being
taught and then to give them a voice to
be able to then push back you know in
different ways and you know whether
you're talking about the the curricula
itself uh the types of lessons that are
being taught or even the the
messages that are being transmitted to
our young children uh the books that are
being introduced parents are absolutely
the number one investors in their
children's future and they should be
partners partners with administrators
and with educators and so it's sad when
i see you know you have federal
officials trying to pit parents against
educators that should not be the case
and that's why i think it's important
that parents not just know what's going
on in their schools but are speaking out
uh and and bringing to bear you know
what they believe should be should
rightly be taught in these schools
keisha there seems to be this conflict
within uh the conversation around this
where people are basically saying you
know well if if you're restricting the
teaching of crt or something along those
lines that you're engaging in something
that is anti-free speech or that is
engaged in some kind of creation of a
speech code what is your response to
people who make that type of argument
from typically from the left and
basically say parents shouldn't have any
kind of role in directing what schools
are teaching their kids
my response is i i'm done i've had it i
have had it we are literally
there's a good response
there is pornography
in k through 12. i mean what is it
really going to take i i was trying to
come on and be more calm but the more i
hear about this it really just
infuriates me i don't know what what
else is it going to take for us to say
you know what
i'm done that's i am calling for a mass
exodus this is too far this is
this is like grooming
a child could not go up and and open up
their laptop and pull up pornography but
they can take a walk to the library at a
public school that we are paying for
these are government-run schools
that is sanctioning pornography so yes
it needs to be out of schools i don't
know
where these people are i don't know what
they're thinking i don't know what these
librarians are this is not just like
some regular banning of you know some
book about something that you don't like
it's pornography to children hello it is
pornography to children
i i this is too much this is it's too
much
well it's it's infuriating to me because
in part as you said this is something
you're paying for you're paying for the
this whole uh type of content to even be
produced patrice i i just find this to
be absurd this is not some
higher ed argument about some
sophisticated or vague you know
philosophical debate this is about the
things that are being taught to our
children on the taxpayer dime
well exactly i mean the discussion about
crt escaped the ivory tower and is now
feeding it's making its way into our our
k-12 level you know i think that not
just about a max exit of students out of
the public school system we need to
empower parents who can't afford to send
their kids to private schools through
you know school choice i think it's so
critically important that parents have
the resources and can take those
resources to better give them better
options for their kids and that may be
a charter school it may be a private
school but our taxpayer dollars we
should be able to determine where that
goes and and i think that is really what
uh the left is worried about they're
worried that not j that there's not just
a mass exodus of parents particularly
parents that probably look like us on
this panel but also that those tax
dollars leave failing public schools and
go into other places
you know i think this is just one of the
most important fights to be having i'm
glad that you are all at the tip of the
spear on this because it is of the
utmost importance to the future of our
nation thank you all for joining me
tonight thank you
thank you